[Music]
Angelina opens up about her split with
Brad inside Angelina's new Vanity Fair
tell all Kevin Frazier is in New York
City for us tonight so Cameron Mathison
here with me now Thank You Nancy and
Angelina crying in the shower trying to
heal hear how she says she and Brad are
moving on from the trouble we're just
coming up for air
that is where Angie says she Brad and
the kids are 10 months after she filed
for divorce the 42 year old star lookin
seductive in the new photos is doing her
healing and private saying quote I do
not want my children to be worried about
me I think it's very important to cry in
the shower and not in front of them
[Music]
Vanity Fair's writer describes Angelina
saying there's anger and pain beneath
the surface answering questions
carefully
Angelina reveals the marriage started to
crumble last summer quote things got bad
then think she didn't want to use that
word she changes it to things became
difficult
Brad admitted to GQ style in May he'd
been quote losing too much Angelina is
also adamant to point out the family's
jet-setting homeschooling hectic
lifestyle wasn't to blame that is and
will remain one of the wonderful
opportunities we are able to give our
children let's embrace being not normal
of course the split took a toll and
Angelina hid a secret illness last year
she developed the Bell's palsy damage to
facial nerves caused one side of her
face to Dru while we could never tell
from photos Angie did acupuncture which
helped her fully recover but the single
mom of six does say her skin has become
drier and she has more gray hairs
she laughed saying I can't tell if it's
menopause or if has just been the year
I've had
the new interview took place June 216 4
days after Angelina moved into her 25
million-dollar Hollywood mansion boxers
were still unpacked and she had no real
visitors yet but does she miss Brad well
Angelina confesses there is one thing
that makes her miss him decorating in
house stop saying quote that was always
Brad fan well Angie also tells Vanity
Fair that she has no interest in working
on another film right now saying that
her life just doesn't have a space for
it
[Music]
you